a real pleasure to be here today and
thank you for for that introduction so I
changed the title a little bit because
of the group that i'm talking to in the
content as well to emphasize some of the
computational issues that have arisen in
the course of the designing the u.s.
incentive auction but before i get
started i really want to mention the
team i stand here and and I get to
proudly tell you about all kinds of
things that I did because I was invited
by the FCC to put together a team to
work on this and my team is an all-star
team I have in alphabetical order here
jonathan levin from stanford who's a
john bates Clark medalist one of the
great economists of his generation Kevin
Layton Brown who's down here computer
science at the University of British
Columbia who will be responsible for
most of what I'm going to tell you about
the computational innovations that we
were engaged in and Ilya sagal down here
another colleague of mine at Stanford
who most of the good economic ideas in
this project came familia so so it's a I
get to stand up here in front of you and
tell you about the team that what the
team produced that we we put together
and it's just a great honor to be here
and I want to thank you guys for for
making this possible for me okay so what
is the incentive auction so not all of
you will know what it is I've I want to
keep this part brief but it all began
with the National Broadband Plan in
March 2010 when the Obama administration
put together a plan that said Congress
should consider expressly expanding the
FCC's authority to enable it to conduct
incentive auctions to my knowledge this
is the first use of the term to conduct
incentive auctions in which incumbent
licensees may relinquish rights and
spectrum assignments to other parties or
to the FCC we want to take some spectral
we want to reallocate spectrum we want
to take it out of its less valuable uses
and begin to put it into more valuable
uses as the demand especially for
wireless broadband has grown
and then the spectrum Congress indeed
enacted the spectrum back in 2012 I've
more or less grade that out in in
February of 2012 in October of 2012 we
by the way our team began work in 2011
before the spectrum act in September of
2011 or in October I guess of 2011 and
the by October of 2012 the FCC had
adopted their framework they gave a
notice of proposed rulemaking which was
basically written by us that said here's
how we propose to deal with this problem
and then there's an appendix to that
which provides the details that was
literally written by us and then in made
2014 the FCC completed the regulatory
process had a report in order and August
of this year the Commission adopted the
procedures public notice establishing
the bidding procedure for next year's
incentive auction scheduled to begin on
March 29 2016 okay so that's what the
incentive auction is it's an attempt to
buy back in this particular case of
television broadcast licenses television
broadcast rights from TV broadcasters in
order to reconfigure those rights and
and reallocate that spectrum and make it
usable for mobile broadband for the
things you know devices like your iPhone
or Android and so on ok so the economic
problem is quite a complicated one
there's about 2,000 UHF television
broadcasters in the United States
counting Canada which is also going to
turn out to be included in this about
3,000 there are currently there were
using channels of 13 i think is 13 it's
13 251 isn't it missing channel 37 which
is channel 37 is is used for medical
devices and and and terrestrial or
rather extraterrestrial search it's
radio telescopes and and and medical
devices so these these are the channels
that are currently used for television
broadcast in the UHF band as of 2012
ninety percent of the u.s. TV viewers
viewed their signals using cab cable or
satellite service so what used to be
very valuable spectrum for delivering
television signals most people are not
getting their television signals over
the air anymore they're getting it
through cable or satellite it's sort of
a waste to have all this large quantity
of high-value spectrum used for for
television broadcast so the idea was
although there's still ten percent that
use it and there's some political issues
there you know spanish-language
television for people low-income
households and such so the issues aren't
quite as straightforward as the 9010
suggests but the but the values the
value of rut of over-the-air broadcast
has clearly declined relative to the the
demand for use in mobile broadband
mobile broadband has been growing very
rapidly the useful spectrum that was
available has mostly been allocated we
need to reallocate spectrum in these in
the useful bands of the lower frequency
bands to to be able to achieve the
continued growth that's anticipated for
these services the plan is again to
create a transition from lower to higher
value use to provide a cash incentive
for broadcasters to relinquish their
spectrum and to cover the costs involved
by selling the new licenses that are
created to mostly to mobile broadband
providers or to some new entrant step to
Google whoever else might want to buy
this spectrum for whatever reasons that
they choose okay now on the complexity
of the problem at least the way it's
formulated today and first pass here's a
TV station somewhere in the Northeast
and each of these pink stations is a
station that cannot be assigned to the
same channel as this TV station without
causing interference in their broadcasts
so one way to a first order
approximation to think about the the
broadcast problems this is not precise
but it's sort of a first order
approximation is to think of it as being
represented by a graph in which each
node is the TV stay
and each arc links to TV stations that
can't be assigned to the same channel
there's some other constraints that are
relevant as well these constraints can
depend on the channel sometimes there
can be other reasons for constraints
treaty treaty reasons for constraints
initially we had certain stations we
weren't allowed to use along the
Canadian border because of agreements
with Canada and along the Mexican border
because of agreements with Mexico so
there was a number of other kinds of
constraints but this to a first order is
the describes the problem this is one of
Kevin's graphs I think this is a I
believe this is one of yours right this
is a spring-loaded representation of the
of the constraint graph and as you can
see it's mostly a total mess the spring
loading is supposed to is supposed to
identify features and it does identify
some you see some things that are of
some interest here like you see clicks
that are that are all hidden in here as
well where you know in the Chicago area
every any two stations in the Chicago
area they all have to have different
channels they know too so that creates
clicks and the graph creates some
structure that can be taken advantage of
but particularly in the Northeast and
throughout much of the United States we
have quite a dense set of connections
the graph is a mess okay so I wrote here
more than 600,000 constraints it turns
out that in the when you take account of
individual channels it's two and a half
million I just learned so the there's
two and a half million constraints in
this in this problem that have to be
respected okay this is um can't believe
i did in 2011 i signed a contract with
the FCC to help them design the option
and the contract specified these goals
for the auction design I still can't
believe I sign this thing but anyway the
the goals goals for the auction design
were efficiency which meant roughly you
know maximizing the value of the
stations that are left on the air
maximizing the amount of value that's
created in the transfer acceptable
revenues whatever that means minimize
gaming and strategic behavior avoid
windfalls to bidders feasible to
implement in an acceptable time frame
voluntaries because nobody has to give
up their spectrum something called a
group payments constraint which we wound
up ignoring so we won't talk much about
that transparent which means roughly
easy to audit and replicate the outcomes
and simple to understand and participate
okay so that was that was the objective
for this for this auction for this
option design okay um challenges okay so
there are so this is the first time I'm
giving this particular version this
track you'll see those of you have seen
this before will have seen a lot of the
economic slides but i want to emphasize
for this group some of the computational
challenges so i'm going to some things
are in here that i've never talked about
in a public lecture before so the first
one in particular challenges in the
product design I'll tell you what that
means in a little while challenges in
computing the efficient allocation
challenges in computing victory prices
to induce to create truthful incentives
challenges and even evaluating the
feasibility of a set of bids whether
given a set of bids if we accept those
bids can we find channels TV channels
for the remaining stations whose bids we
didn't take that are jointly feasible
that don't create excessive interference
okay then there were economic challenges
in addition to these computational
challenges can we do all this and make
it easy for bidders it's this is really
important it turns out that the end of
these anybody who knows anything real
about auctions knows that the single
most important thing that an auction is
participation if you don't get the
bidders you don't have an auction I mean
you've got to get people in and the if
we had something that was dauntingly
hard for bidders to understand it's a
viable option for bidders to say you
know what I'll transact maybe after the
auction with somebody else who sold
their stage it's a viable option not to
dissipate we've got to make bidding easy
in order for bidders to participate and
this is a really complicated
optimization problem so how are we going
to do that so that's that was a serious
economic challenge discouraging
collusion which is always a problem in
auctions deciding how many channels to
clear the FCC it didn't tell us how many
channels to clear they say we're trying
to get some guys to sell and we'd like
some people to buy how much spectrum
should we clear how do we decide that
avoiding windfalls said you know in
particular there's some small stations
in New York that have you know that
they're not very valuable they cover a
relatively small number a relatively
small number of viewers but they
interfere with Manhattan just as much as
a big station does and some some of the
big stations are being offered nine
hundred million dollars to go off the
air do we also have to offer that amount
to a little station to get the state you
know how do we avoid windfalls for
bidders and keep the cost of the whole
process reasonable and then there are
other kinds of challenges diplomatic
challenges the this how do we coordinate
with Canada and Mexico that basically
the entire population of Canada lives
within TV broadcast distance of the US
border and their stations all interfere
with us stations and some coordination
is necessary mexican border well Mexico
City is further away but there's still a
lot of interference along the Mexican
border and Mexico it turns out even has
in its constitution or a limitation that
have to be a certain number of
television channels it turns out this
was an anti Carlos Slim thing they were
worried about the the their politics
their communications being monopolized
by the richest man in the world or I
don't know if he's richest this year but
some years the richest man in the world
and and so they actually have a
constitutional restriction against
cooperating on this and so we have
diplomatic challenges measurement
challenges how do we tell weather
stations interfere political challenges
which we won't even go into today
there's a you know there were a lot of
different kinds of challenges I'm going
to emphasize the computational and
economic
challenges today okay uh the first
challenge I want to talk about is
product design and what the FCC is
actually going to do is it's going to
buy the right to turn off broadcasters
using UHF TV channels or to get them to
switch out of the UHF band into VHF band
or something but basically to turn off
stations that are in the UHF band
broadcasters who whose rights are not
purchased are protected no other TV
station can interfere with very much of
that stations covered population so one
of the things the FCC had to decide was
what very much mint and they decided you
know that it's a tradition in this
industry that you round everything to
hold percentages and therefore it's
considered that if we interfere with
less than 0.5% of the station's viewers
were not interfering ok this is the well
estate you know the you don't have to
make new law the regular law and
regulations that said your not
interfering if you have you know if in
whole numbers of percents your night
interfering everything was measured in
whole numbers of percent so that's the
regulation now it turns out that when we
were designing this auction and so this
again is something I've never discussed
in a public audience before the we were
looking at alternatives so we looked at
our alternative that said look you know
you could be a station and we could move
you to a new channel and you could take
a half percent interference from cabin
and a half percent interference familia
and half percent and interference from
from Joe and end and you add it all up
and maybe you're taking you know quite a
bit of interference maybe we should try
to express the interference in terms of
the sum of all the interference you take
but I remember Ilya pointing out most of
the time the interference came from the
same direction and if we drew a Venn
diagram we would discover that you know
was the same population that was being
interfered with by by different
television stations so we would need to
take all that into account anyway the
the measurement and computational
complexity made us decide to not do this
that is to say instead of measuring so
so this was measurement and
computational complexity affecting the
products that are being bought and sold
in the auction we had we had considered
offsets to say you know what we're
taking some stations off the air so
maybe Kevin station over here is taking
some extra interference familiar but
it's no longer taking interference from
Chris um you know maybe we should get
credit for that that's not creating
extra interference so we talked about
doing offsets that all got thrown out
the window again it's measurement and
computation was was affecting the
details of how this auction had to be
designed and we talked about trying so
it could be it could very well turn out
that when we're all done there are some
places where there there's a TV station
that we wouldn't they had we would not
have had to buy that station if it if we
could have said gee would you accept
ninety six percent of your only four
percent interference and we'll pay you
to accept the small reduction from
ninety-nine percent which were entitled
to to have any way down to ninety-six
percent we might have been able to get
away with paying a smaller sum of money
to buy fractional amounts of
interference provided we could keep
track of all that during the course of
the option again it was computation that
made that impossible so this this option
designed the products that were offered
the fact that we're buying stations and
taking them off the air rather than
buying fractions of the station this is
deeply affected by our understanding of
what we could compute what we could
measure in what we could compute okay so
again just in terms of challenges that
come from computational complexity
challenges in computing optimal
allocation so there were experiments be
even before we were hired by an
operations research team that we're
using mixed integer program formulations
and they were trying they spent a lot of
time on the formulations trying to make
their formulations compact and
random on cplex and on Groby and they
ran them for weeks on the on whatever
machines they were using and they turned
it off after about two weeks when it
appeared that in the second week they
weren't getting much further improvement
in the computations and looked at what
they had and they were able to prove
that they were getting ninety-seven
percent of the optimal value they
thought that was pretty good they could
use that kind of computation they
thought to to run an auction and they
wanted to run a victory so the initial
proposal before we before we join this
project was to run a big reaction that
is to compute thank you guys all know
the victory price formula the if s
denotes a collection I don't wonder how
I got a 3rd l in there of TV stations
and if SNF means that the collection is
feasible that there's a there exists an
acceptable channel assignment four
stations s then the victory price for a
station that goes off the air is the
difference between two maximum values ok
it's you solve to optimization problems
you take the difference the problem with
this is that with 2,000 stations a one
percent error and in one of these
optimizations would if the other
optimization were exact would lead to a
two thousand percent price in your on
average for the Vickrey auction remember
each station has a value that's about a
twentieth of a percent of the total
value and we're calculating is a
difference of two total values so if
you're making a one-percent computation
earn one of those total values that's a
two thousand percent computation error
for a victory price about it's way too
big and in fact one of the things Ilya
noticed immediately when he was looking
at the list of decree prices that came
out is that some of them were negative
that the you know they were getting
total nonsense and it's just this
enviable so we couldn't calculate decree
prices ok so again computational limits
affecting the auction design and then
then there was the question of what what
you say to the bidders suppose I could
do this suppose we suppose we could get
to the point where we got
really high you know accuracy in the
computation and and I go to Tim over
there and well Tim maybe too
sophisticated for this but I let's primp
to mr. bitter I say to you you know
trust me it's in your interest to tell
me what your station is worth I'm going
to do this computation there's no prayer
that you're going to understand what I'm
doing or that you'll be able to
replicate it but at the end I'm going to
name a price and that and you cannot do
better than to report truthfully and I'm
the government trust me you know it just
doesn't fly we're not going to you know
even if there are some people who would
go alludu trust the government certainly
we can't get all these are mostly small
businessmen we're not going to get all
these TV station owners to just trust us
in a calculation this is a really
complicated calculation so what are we
going to do is we have a computation
problem and we have to make it easy for
the bitters to participate and we will
by the way make it easy for the bidders
to participate as you'll see in a little
while okay victory rules aren't just
aren't acceptable for this okay so then
it was the question the challenge of
finding feasibility so suppose we have
just one set of bids and we want to know
can we accept this set of bids is it
possible to given a set of bids to take
those stations off the earth to find
channels for the other stations well
that's a graph coloring problem and I
don't have to tell you guys that's an
np-complete class of problems the when
we ran the best current we're going to
try to run this probably will have about
a minute per problem during the course
of the auction we don't know where stop
with okay okay but let's say we have a
minute per problem during the course of
the auction you know the median run
times on all the salvors that were
available on these probably general we
ran some simulations generated the kinds
of problems we thought might come up in
the auction we couldn't find any solver
that had median run times of less than
five minutes and by the way median that
the median means fifty percent of the
problems are I don't know you know I
can't tell whether i can accept those
bids and every time you can't tell
whether you can accept a bid that means
you know this collection of it means you
can't accept this collection of bids
because you need to be sure
when you accept a collection of it's
that it's actually feasible to assign TV
channels to the remaining stations so
that would drastically increase the cost
of running the auction every time out
every time we we say we couldn't solve
that problem that that's a big cost
increase for us okay so the goal was to
get this down to something like
ninety-nine percent in a minute or less
the more or less that's been
accomplished something on something on
that order okay so what kinds of
questions the do I want to talk about
that were posed for the consultants what
can the FCC do about the graph coloring
challenge and this number is only around
20,000 now I was estimating it was
around 200,000 when I wrote this but
Kevin tells me it's only around 20,000
problems to solve during the auction
only what will we do when the when the
when a computation times out what's
going to happen in the auction can the
FCC actually make it easy for
broadcasters to bid effectively can we
create a strategy proof option that
doesn't involve optimization is that
even useful if the bitter neither
understands the computation or trusts us
to do it correctly okay how should the
auction identify winners when
optimization and even sometimes
feasibility checking may fail how many
channels should we try to clear how
should the FCC try to accommodate
broadcasters who may want to share a
channel so here's something that was a
big problem for us in the last year the
the the technology is such that the
these six megahertz channels which are
there for historic reasons because it
used to be what you needed to carry a
standard-definition analog signal they
can carry sometimes to high-definition
signals at least 1080i signals they can
they know they've successfully sustained
in in multiplexing and that means you
know we could we could have these two
guys over here they could decide they're
going to sell one of their broadcast
channels and share the other one and
accept how the hundred million dollars
or whatever we're offering for a channel
and both stay on the air
you know sharing a single channel so we
want to encourage people to do that but
as the bidders try to do that they start
talking to each other guess what you
can't make these agreements without
talking to each other and now we have a
problem that you know some network let's
say I on network some network that has
stations in Los Angeles in Chicago and
New York he wants to talk to Fox in Los
Angeles and he wants to talk to CBS in
New York and whatever so you have some
bitter that's talking to all the other
bidders the risks of collusion are
enormous in this kind of setting how do
we get how do we let these guys talk to
each other without without colluding
what kind of rules can we make so
actually that if this were a top two
economists I'd spend more time on that
but for this for this group that's going
to get short shrift and here's the kind
of University of Chicago Economics
Department question why don't we just
leave it to the market that is why don't
we just say you know you guys are you
own your own your spectrum sell it to
whoever you want you know so the if I
have some time I will I will talk about
that but I think you guys probably don't
need convincing that this is not
something that a bunch of bilateral
trades can work out without some kind of
central organization to clear the
spectrum okay so let's take these
questions in some kind of order what can
we do about the graph coloring challenge
so this is largely largely the work that
Kevin and his team did at the University
of British Columbia so I'm going to talk
about four of the strategies that they
adopted one of them was machine learning
to train a parameterised SAT solver a
heuristic to run fast for a set of
instances that were generated by
simulations and I remember the the we
first became aware of how much you guys
had to contribute when we saw the
performance of the machine learning on
clasp which took its average runtime its
median runtime down from something over
five minutes down to a seventh of a
second as I recall in fairly short order
and that was totally amazing that wasn't
all improvements to class I remember
that was partly problem loading and a
number of
other things but still it was just
amazing improvement a second strategy is
which I know Kevin is famous for is is
creating portfolios of algorithms the
idea is that if you have two algorithms
for these NP complete problems if you
can arrange that lets say the run times
were statistically independent and one
of them solve eighty percent of the
problems in a minute the other one also
solved eighty percent of the problems in
a minute if you take whichever one
answers first you have ninety-six
percent of the problems only four
percent are failing in a minute if you
could get into tistic alee independent
runtimes well what's really need is that
the set of problems on which they fail
within the available time are mostly
disjoint and and the team is still
working on ways to what families of
algorithms have these properties so they
can be used together to drastically
reduce runtimes third third strategy was
pre identifying unconstrained stations
so the the idea is that even though this
interference graph is very complex maybe
there's you know maybe Tulsa Oklahoma
it's always possible to find a channel
for a station in Tulsa Oklahoma no
matter what you're doing everywhere else
and if you can identify cities like that
you can just remove them from the graph
and if you're lucky you disconnect the
graph into components and make the
problems easier and make pieces of the
problem reusable and then the fourth
strategy that I'll mention here was that
building a searchable cache of problem
components and no solutions for them
these were if you can generate problems
that that recur and that you can look up
the solutions very fast well you can
look up the solutions that's very fast
when you can do it it turns out that
there was some really clever work done
here the it's not just problems that
you've encountered before that that are
useful to put in your cash it turns out
that if you know that that you can't
pack stations a B and C let's say you
can't find channels for all of stations
a B and C and you've already got a
solution that has a B and D
and somebody s can you pack see as well
well that's a superset of ABC which you
had before and and you know that if you
can't pack a station you can't pack any
superset of that station so when you
search the database if you can identify
supersets you can also eliminate those
or say that those are infeasible and
similarly if you have a set of stations
that you know you can pack then you know
you can pack any subset as well you can
find channels for any subset and that
also speeds the speeds the calculation
you can you can search the database for
super sets and subsets of those two
kinds of problems so these things
together led to drastic improvements the
FCC is very they're happier with it than
we are we keep trying to do better
because we understand how much money is
at stake in these in these auctions they
each percent well we think that there's
still hundreds of millions of dollars at
play and possibly even billions of
dollars at play in the auction from just
small improvements and feasibility
checking the FCC thinks we did great and
we should stop bothering them with
improvements so the but anyway this is
this is what's going on okay can we make
it easy for broadcasters to bid
effectively okay so this is a really
complex auction the what the Chairman
originally wanted to do when we went and
says okay we don't need a victory
auction we're just going to have an
auction everybody says a price and we
somehow or another figure out what the
cheapest way is to clear spectrum we try
to minimize as best we can and then we
pay the bitters their prices they named
okay can you imagine bidding under
auction like that I mean just think
about how hard that is you know you're
in there and you don't know what
everybody else is bidding and you have
no idea if you're trying I advise
bidders in a lot of auctions and one of
the things we do is mock auctions we go
through what would happen in various
scenarios but we can't even compute
what's going to happen in scenarios here
this is really hard for bidders I expect
that if we had we done that and I
convinced I remember being there
convincing the chairman of the FCC that
this was really a dumb idea there would
be a lot of broadcasters who would say
I don't know what to do no I'm not going
to bid on an option like that and you
know the stations are worth a lot I'll
transact after the auction that be a
disaster for us we we need it to be easy
to bid in this auction and that's a
requirement and but is it even useful
can we make this strategy proof so that
it's very easy to bid is that even
useful if the bidder doesn't understand
the computations and doesn't trust the
FCC to do them correctly so the channel
so this is the challenge about making it
easy to bid and what we wanted at the
time when we set this up we said for
single minded bidders for a bitter who
either is either going to keep this
station or sell it and this is looking
at to any of these other options it
should be a dominant strategy to bid
straightforwardly but moreover we said
it should be easy the bitter should find
that dominance to be clear even if they
don't understand how the prices are
computed and even if they're not so sure
that the FCC understands either okay
that's the the kind of constraint on
mechanism design we were looking for and
the solution we came up with is the
descending clock auction format and
here's roughly how it works for you so
you are a bitter and you're
participating in an auction in your
station is worth 8 million dollars to
you you and the the FCC invites you to
an auction and it says the opening price
in the auction for your station is going
to be 45 million dollars you saying that
sounds pretty interesting my station is
worth 8 how does this option work and
say well we're going to offer you 45
million dollars we're gonna see how many
offers we get and if we have more offers
than we need then we're going to start
reducing the prices so instead of
offering you 45 million dollars the next
round we're going to offer you 42
million dollars and if when I offer you
45 million dollars or at any point in
the auction and when I offer you 42
million dollars if you say no then
you're out you keep your station and
that's fine and if you say yes then
you're in you might get 42 million
dollars or I might reduce the price and
give you another offer now there you are
and you're sitting there Joe you're
sitting there and I figure you've got
this 8 million dollar station I've made
this
2 million dollar offer to you you have
no idea where i came up with 42 million
dollars and you don't know you think
it's i tell you the next number is going
to be 39 you say that's not fair it
should be something else you don't know
what the next offer is going to be but
you know damn well that you're going to
say yes to 42 million dollars because
your stations only worth 8 million
dollars to you you don't have to know
how I calculated these prices and you
know you don't even have to believe that
I understood how to calculate the prices
you know that the right answer to an
offer of 42 million dollars is yes and
that's and that's as simple as it gets
right so this is this is the idea and
the bitter finds it optimal to bid
truthfully regardless of how the prices
are computed or how the FCC decides
whether or not it wants to buy your
station at those prices so i have a
graduate student on the market this year
shengli that has actually this
description is benefited a little bit
from sheng gu's comments he's at you
defined this is a new formal concept the
concept of obviously strategy proof
mechanisms and so this is a new concept
in game theory and his cos definition is
that at any information set during the
course of the game the best payoff that
you can get from any deviation is no
better than the worst continuation
payoff from playing truthfully to the
end and that's it so this is to make it
obvious at any you know so you're
playing in this auction and the best
that can happen if you say no is you get
0 and the worst that can happen if you
say yes if you get zero it can't be it's
just obvious that it's not in your
interest to deviate and sheng wu has
done a of these mechanisms what you can
implement what some beautiful
equivalences which i won't have time to
tell you about but the the thing you
need to know is that it Vic reactions
don't have this property they're not
obviously strategy proof it's not the
case that the sending options to buy
have this property and that this
property also implies something else
that we cared about namely that this
mechanism is
group strategy proof that and victory
auctions in general or not what it means
to be group strategy proof is that there
isn't any group of bidders that can make
a joint deviation that strictly benefits
all of them and why is that the case
well during the course of this auction
there's going to be some guy who's first
to deviate and when you deviate for the
first time since this is an obviously
strategy proof mechanism there's nothing
that can happen that can make it in your
interest to deviate did the best thing
that can happen when you deviate is no
better than the worst thing that happens
when you don't deviate so for the first
guy it can't be optimal to deviate so
there can't be any group of agents who
can have a profitable strictly
profitable joint deviation okay and
other things okay discouraging collusion
so I've already said a little bit of
this the am i doing on time here the
kinds of collusion economists recognize
different kinds of collusion one I've
just talked about as joint deviations in
the auction another would people usually
think about is deviations with side
payments that is I make a deal with you
I make a deal with filia over there and
I say oh yeah you know you bid in a
certain way I realize it's not in your
interest but i'll pay you something i'll
write you a check and and and you can do
something that's beneficial to me and
and it'll be worth your while to make
this deviation that's a deviation with
side payments and the those are deterred
mostly by antitrust and by by the law by
basically by criminal penalties when if
you have a deviation with side payments
you try to write somebody a check
there's a paper trail or your you show
up somewhere with a box full of cash the
that's a harder kind of that that's
easier to detect and sort of harder to
arrange then a joint deviation in which
two CEOs whisper to one another you know
why don't we both did you know twice as
much and see if we can get a higher
price and these joint deviations are
deterred by the auction rules and these
kind of deviations we can only hope will
be deterred by a criminal enforcement so
that we can avoid those kinds of
we also have problems with cross market
collusion and market power issues some
of these some of the bidders are not
individual station owners they're their
networks that own stations in many
cities and here they keep the
economist's will recognize that the key
trick here is that stations in different
cities or complements not substitutes in
this auction and therefore what we worry
about when we worry about collusion is
that if you have a bunch of stations
that are substitutes that the that what
what some of the sellers will do is
they'll withhold supply in order to
drive up the price when their
complements you don't have that that
trick available to you so we're much
less worried about collusion by or about
joint strategies about networks that on
stations in many cities because it's
much harder to manipulate an auction
when the things you're selling or
compliments okay um and I've already
described to you about the wide
descending clock option is group
strategy proof so let me push on how
many channels should the FCC try to
clear okay so now here's something we
you know we don't know what the TV's did
which TV stations are willing to
participate we don't know how much
verizon and AT&T and t-mobile and
whoever dish are willing to pay how many
channels should we clear okay so that's
a that's an issue that the FCC had to
work out so what we suggested to them
yeah and what they will do in fact is
that there's a there's a pointed wit
that they said first of all really high
opening prices for the for the stations
that say here's where we're going to
start the clock auction at some really
high prices and then we have them
register they register and on March 29th
they commit to once there they register
we've checked that they're eligible
which you go through all the legal steps
on in March 29th the registered stations
say okay here's what we commit to at the
opening price we either commit or we
don't commit to sell our station at the
opening price and actually they have
more options than that but let's just
keep things simple and say that they
we announced the final opening prices
they say yes or no on march 29th and
then we do an optimization and we take a
couple of weeks and we say well given
all these stations if we could buy any
of them that we want what's the most
largest number of channels we could
clear across the United States with very
little in a very little interference and
so we do that and we imagine that what's
going on in the in the background and
this is a simplified example as if
spectrum were uniform which it isn't and
I'll show you the real algorithm in a
moment but uh this is the way economist
sort of like to think about it you have
quantity along the horizontal axis and
price on the vertical axis and just
imagine that these were homogeneous
products for a moment and i'll give you
the real stuff in it afterwards so we
set some ambitious quantity that's based
on the registration these are people who
have said they're willing to sell at the
opening prices this is how much we can
sell and then we run a reverse auction
and we let the price ball and a forward
auction and we let the price and
determine what will have to pay for
spectrum to the sellers and then we run
a forward auction ascending price and
see this is what we're going to receive
from the buyers and oops that's not good
we're paying more than we're getting
we're suffering a loss so this target
isn't achievable so what we're going to
do is we're going to reduce the quantity
target and then we're going to let the
price continued to fall in the reverse
auction and continue to rise in the
forward auction but hoops that's still
not good enough so we're going to reduce
the quantity target again remember we
don't get to see these supply and demand
curves but they go and and oops oh yeah
okay now the price that we're getting
for spectrum in the forward option is
higher than the price that we're paying
in the reverse auction and the so these
auctions stop and then continue and and
not only that we've also raised enough
money Dimitra meet our revenue targets
which the FCC sets I won't go into how
the revenue target is set and
that's how we determine the quantity
it's this is the this is the algorithm
the actual algorithm it's that it's the
same idea we have prices with different
prices for different stations i'll be
showing you that in a little while but
we have prices falling in the reverse
option we set an initial clearing target
we have maximum opening bids and minimum
opening bids prices falling in the
reverse option rising in the forward
option checking the closing rule if yes
we're done if no we reduce the clearing
target and we iterate okay and that's
the now we're doing this without uniform
prices with different prices for each
station and I'll tell you a little bit
more about the reverse auction prices in
a moment okay all right how should we
identify winners when optimization and
even some feasibility checking fail will
I've already suggested to you that the
trick is going to be a clock auction and
I've shown you roughly how that works so
here is something that's a variation of
this example is actually an older
algorithm due to debris summer and vara
2007 and this airline overbooking the
analogy is thank you to Kevin for
sharing these slides this these are this
is Kevin's presentation of the algorithm
and it looks like this so the idea here
is remember we already have stations on
the year so it's like we already have
passengers on on an airplane and we've
decided to take some stations off the
air they have fewer channels that's like
deciding to use a smaller airplane so we
use a smaller airplane and all of a
sudden all those seats that were down in
the middle they disappeared and these
guys don't have seats anymore okay so
and moreover we don't have enough seats
for everybody so we start with an offer
the airline substitutes a smaller plane
and opens the bidding with an offer of
compensation of a thousand dollars and
so we have a bunch of guys who are not
on the you know who don't have seats
anymore there's an offer of a thousand
dollars the
a thousand dollars by the way the some
of these guys said yeah I'll take a
thousand dollars I'll go off I'll give
up my seat for a thousand dollars these
are a bunch of people in first class and
business class and coach there's a yeah
for a thousand dollars I'd give up my
seat Miss AG we have more seats than we
need we're not going to offer a thousand
dollars we're only going to offer eight
hundred dollars and in this auction and
then some of these guys say well you
know at eight hundred dollars that's not
enough and now enough people have gone
back to first class that it's full but
there's still space in a business class
and economy class and we say okay well
we don't have any more space for you
guys in first class you've accepted
eight hundred dollars you've got it
eight hundred dollars for you but we're
going to continue to lower the price for
business class and coach at that lower
price some more people say nope that's
not enough we continue to lower the
price more people go back onto the plane
business class is now full so we need
these two guys there's no space for them
anymore so we buy them at five hundred
dollars and then we continue to lower
the price four hundred dollars some of
these guys go back three hundred dollars
we still have space on in coach two
hundred fifty dollars oops coaches full
will pay those guys two hundred fifty
dollars and there we have an auction
that has determined prices for each
individual class from one single
descending clock price and if these
things were New York LA and the Midwest
then that could indicate how we
determine prices for TV stations now the
New York LA in the Midwest also doesn't
really describe it we actually are going
to be checking feasibility separately
for every different station because they
all have different interference
constraints and at every point during
the course of this will be checking
let's go back here is the room for this
guide is there somewhere is there some
seed I could put him in is there some
seed I could put in and here the
feasibility checking is easy you know
you you're entitled to a coach class
seat do I have a seat in coach in the
actual auction what we'll be doing
is solving the graph coloring problem or
a variation of a graph coloring problem
saying is there is there a channel for
you and if there's not a channel for you
then I can't lower your price anymore I
have to I have to leave you I have to
buy your station and i'll pay you the
current clock price ok so that was the
that's the algorithm now the first key
difference so this doesn't describe
exactly what we're doing there there are
several key differences the first key
differences is that the flyers the
passengers or if you will which are the
stations they're actually considered one
at a time during the course of the
auction prices during the processing are
decreased by small increments and a
flyer and the flyer is considered
infeasible if it can't be shown to be
feasible so you know we won't always be
able to solve these problems they're NP
it's an np-complete class so once in a
while we'll we'll just get a timeout and
when we get a timeout we're going to buy
that station this sequential processing
of lloyds overshooting it means that we
never lower the price by too much but it
can also lead to unequal prices for
passengers in the same cabin you can
imagine that I was lowering those prices
for business class passengers one at a
time until there were no seats left in
business class and then depending on
whether you came early in the processing
or later in the process and you could
have gotten a slightly different price
so those are they that's the drawback I
think it's not much of a drawback so
that's how we do that second the
organization's matters we're trying
these are hard problems and we're going
to do a lot of parallel computations
exactly how many remains to be seen but
the the hardest part for the FCC is
checking whether there's a seat
available for each passenger that is
there any way to assign channels so that
I so that I can take Steve to Delos over
there and and give him a give him a
channel and also give channels to
everybody else who is on the or say I
made you look up from your PC there see
the so the is there any way is there any
way to do that and so that's the hardest
part and what we're going to do is we're
going to have parallel processors
running
ideally we'll be checking in parallel
all of the passengers that don't have
seats at any given moment and as long as
none of them as long as all of them are
are willing to accept that price all
these calculations are relevant but as
soon as one of them says as soon as I
find one for whom there's not room
that's not each time that some passenger
rejects its offer of so that passenger
now has to go on the plane now I have to
restart the calculations for all the
other passengers because i have a new
coloring problem now now including
Stephen now that i've added events to
the to the plane now checking whether
there's a seat for steve is a new
problem than the one that i was solving
before so so the order of processing is
going to turn out to matter and with
limited processing order the computing
powers use best if each passengers bid
gets processed when the availability of
its seat becomes known so the so the
idea is I'm running this feasibility
check and instead of using a fixed order
of processing if it turns out that I'm
processing in the round and I managed to
solve Vince's problem first and I say
yep there's a seat for prevents I can
process Vince then I've had all of my
processors are still occupied and
whether the answer to his question is
yes or no I either restart or I don't
but all of my processors continue to run
whereas if I have a fixed orbit of
processing which is what the FCC has
right now that we're trying to talk them
out of the if you have a fixed order of
processing then what could happen is it
might be that Vince is the next guy to
be processed and I finished checking
Ilya and Kevin and everybody else and I
know it and I have all these processors
idle while I run into the one problem
that takes me 10 minutes to solve
instead of two tenths of a second and I
end up wasting ninety percent 95% even
larger percentages of my processing
power with idle processors because I'm
processing these stations in
wrong order so the auction design itself
these tiny changes in the orbit of
processing and the options i have a huge
consequence for how much processing time
I can actually devote to each of these
problems and this can this can make
hundreds of billions of dollars of
difference in the performance of the
auction it's really it's totally amazing
that the insuit these these
computational issues are deeply involved
in getting the auction design right okay
I'm pretty much almost out of time so
let me just quickly say a couple of
other differences as in the example of
prices in the incentive auction do
depend on one single clock that's that's
going down but unlike the example I'm
not going to have this I'm not going to
be offering the same price to every
station I'm trying to avoid paying
windfalls in the auction and I have some
small station in New York and some big
station in new york and i just don't
have to offer the same amount of money
to the small station is the big station
in order to get it to you know to stay
in the air i know that it's you know
it's only serving a tenth as many it has
only a tenth as many people in its
service area so why should I offer it
the same price so i don't so stations
price depends on its service population
and also i want to have some sense of if
i buy that station how much it
contributes to making the the graph
coloring easier so i'm also going to
count the number of edges that come out
of that that station that is the number
of interference links and i'm going to
use those two things to determine the
price that i offered actually the
formula that's used that the FCC adopted
is it multiplies the service population
by the number of links and takes the
square root of that product and that's
the index that it uses to adjust the
comparative prices of different stations
okay and so I'll just say this deferred
acceptance clock auctions that's the the
mechanism we've been describing to you
they're obviously strategy proof that as
formula formulated by Lee their group
strategy proof they uniquely /
reserved winners privacy so here's
another for just for the sake of culture
here there was a famous auction in New
Zealand some 20 years ago and which was
a second price auction the highest bid
was a million dollars the second highest
bid was six dollars those of you who
know second price options I didn't get
any laughter from this room the the that
means somebody been a million dollars
and actually only had to pay six dollars
this made headlines as you might imagine
we decided we didn't want headlines like
that in the in our auction so we want to
we don't want anybody to know they don't
want us to know and we don't want the
public to know how low the bidders would
have been able would have been willing
to go nobody ever finds out that you
know Ilia would have taken five bucks
for his station he was almost bankrupt
and that he walked away with 25 million
you know he doesn't want anybody to know
that and we don't want anybody to know
that in this auction this auction does
not reveal that information and it's the
only auction is essentially the only
auction that has that property this
option requires only heuristics it
doesn't require exact optimization it
can accommodate all kinds of alternative
goals and constraints unlike the Vickrey
auction so for example we can have a
budget constraint we do have a budget
constraint we there's a limit on how
much we can pay the bidders in the
reverse auction and if the if the
options too expensive we reduce the
clearing target we can adjust that you
cannot incorporate a budget constraint
into a victory option it doesn't work so
the so we have a strategy proof auction
that works even with budget constraints
we can accommodate virtual cost
objectives for those of you know what
that means we can we can use the these
scoring rules these different prices to
adjust the prices that are offered to
different stations in a way to make this
in expected cost minimizing auction I
don't have time to do the detail of that
but it it's doable and they also and
this was one of the first questions that
the Chairman asked me you know four
years ago or three and three years ago I
guess that ilya and i had had proved
back then you know so wait a minute okay
i love these proper
this auction but isn't this going to be
more expensive if you make it in
people's interest to bid truthfully
doesn't that raise costs and the truth
is that we can't really answer that
question because we don't know how
people are going to bid in a sealed bid
auction where they pay as bid so we did
the best we can so we have sort of this
thing that will make everybody shiver
but the what we did was we calculated
the undaunted full information Nash
equilibrium of the corresponding Paytas
bid auction that's all we can do and it
turns out we get a revenue equivalence
result which is to say the cost is the
same at the at this Nash equilibrium for
the dominant strategy mechanism and for
the pages bid mechanism in other words
there is no reason to think based on
equilibrium theory we have no particular
reason to think that this auction has a
worst cost performance than the pages
bid option that providing this dominant
strategy incentives and even obviously
dominant strategy incentives it has a
net cost to the FCC of zero okay and
that's pretty much it this is the this
is the FCC web page for the incentive
auctions March 29th keep your eyes
peeled this is you know this is a
historic event both for the
telecommunications industry and for
market design and we were very very
excited about it thank you very much
yeah oh yeah so the I mean you know
really is smiling here because the I I
anticipated this and the the reason we
have such a simple formula so we you
know we had all we had all kinds of
simulations that were run about what the
effective cost would be if we did it in
various ways and I knew you know if you
start putting in you know that you're
going to take the population and based
on simulations you're going to raise it
to the PowerPoint 63 and you know you're
gonna people are going to start arguing
about that so so we put together this
formula that we multiplied these two
things together and to the power
one-half and we said look you know
here's what you say and this is what
they do say in the you know that that
you know is it dude this is this is
sensible it actually works pretty well
in the simulations and it's sensible and
the we have stations that have said that
it makes sense to them that they should
be paid in part based on their
population and having these two things
multiplied together and with the power
one-half means if you have some station
that has causes twice as much
interference and has twice the
population you offer it twice the price
ok the it has this you know just common
sense attributes and so the getting the
getting the formula right so that it was
something that that's common sense
that's based on we also cite some
literature which indicates that using
square roots of the number of edges is
is helpful in in other heuristics as
being so that's helpful it has this this
fairness property that I've just
described to you and and and then we
just hunkered down and and and took
criticism from people who thought
especially if you were a small station
owner you didn't like this at all the
small station owners made a political
appeal where they wanted a lower
exponent on the on population so that
they got a larger fraction of what the
what the big stations got
and the FCC said no
oh you mean if there's if the TV
stations were so Congress only
authorizes the FCC to do this once okay
so that's in the current legislation of
course if it's successful you know you
but the the other the other problem that
the station owners have is that the
legislation does not say that they
actually own these rights they're
allowed to sell them in this auction but
the rights could expire they could have
lesser rights in a future auction but
but you're right that in it would what
we always do this small world stuff and
we do modeling we say you know here's
the problem here's your incentives in
this context if you set it in a larger
context and give people more choices you
won't it won't necessarily and the
larger context be obviously strategy
protected won't be obviously strategy
proof in the larger context it's being
marketed as a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity absolutely and people are
treating it that way these price the
prices that we quote if you've seen the
prices out I mean anybody who follows
this industry it's headlines every day
you know we of you everyday headlines
you know nine hundred million dollar
opening price whatever the the the
industry is is all abuzz the networks
that the FCC thought would never
participate in this auction because
they're the most valuable Fox CBS you
know ABC they're all saying gee we're
going to offer stations in this auction
I mean these these prices have drawn
everybody out of the woodwork the and
we'll see the option will determine the
final prices but the FCC has has set
high enough opening prices to really
encourage participation
politically no it's oh so Congress so
Congress said um so this it's actually
changed over time the Congress said that
the FCC's auctions had to cover the cost
of relocating stations which they
Congress set to be 1.75 billion dollars
plus the cost of of the public safety of
communication system but it turns out
that the previous auction covered the
cost of the public safety communication
system so that piece is now zero so the
the net revenue target is now pretty low
it's just you know 1.75 billion plus the
class is running the option you know two
billion to unit 2 billion something it's
it's a this these are this auction the
pundits have numbers in the range
depends who you talk to but the numbers
that you hear our numbers in the range
of forty to eighty billion dollars in
this site's a big deal it's a huge
auction and and two billion dollars they
think of is almost de minimis in that
context
so that's a political differences about
that the you know the commissioners
differ and how they it's up to the
commissioners it's their political
appointees they differ in the weight
that they place on revenue and on
clearing a lot of spectrum I think the
Obama administration is very committed
to clearing the they made a commitment
to try to clear 500 megahertz of
spectrum and various bands to make it
available for further what they call
this the infrastructure of the 21st
century it says in one of the OMB
reports and they're very committed to
clearing a lot of spectrum I think the
Republicans put a greater weight on
relative to the Democrats anyway on
Deficit Reduction and and think that
it's important to make a you know a nice
chunk of money off of this and so those
but the weight between those two things
that's above my pay grade that's that's
a political decision
so we got that excellent question and I
think that's the the audit ability
that's the hardest part to audit and the
FCC is worried about that now but the
hardest part to audit is the is
replicating the feasibility checks we do
know that the stations that we find to
be feasible our feasible because we we
do have independent checks to verify
that the solutions that are delivered
our actual solutions but the the time
out and the stations that are infeasible
presumably you can you can double check
that the time outs and that's hard to
replicate
but we've gotten a lot of what we want
or what we're doing what we're
struggling with right now is is the
efficient use of price we think that
that it could be up to a factor of a
hundred in terms of the amount of
processing time that could be wasted and
we think there could be a fair amount of
money engaged in that you know we're
Network you know involvement we're not
really we're running simulations now to
try to get an estimate of how having
effectively longer time outs affects the
the net cost of the auction we got most
of what we thought was right in this
design within the time frame that we had
you know you saw that there were some
compromises we made some of the
compromises we made we would need years
more to see whether we had any hope of
doing things that we could do with in
with months more are things like getting
better use of the parallel processing
which and we'll see how important that
is as a result of simulations
I experienced the air face between
people and automated systems across the
board are fairly primitive
so they the software that will be used
for the auction itself is all new and
it's and it's being really thoroughly in
the subsequent to Obamacare the
government is the amount of testing is
mind-boggling it's ridiculous actually
the the interfaces are great they for
the auction itself the hardest software
problems associated with the auction or
all the traditional systems that are
involved you know just doing the
registrations all the old stuff that
should be straightforward that's the
stuff that the that were more likely to
choke on the new software is the FCC has
spent the money to do it well and and
and they're really excellent interfaces
and I'm expecting those to work
beautifully
no so the stations that are similarly
situated will never differ by more than
one increment it could be that in the in
the order of processing during so during
around we're gonna there's human rounds
where what we call human internally
within the team we refer to human rounds
and machine rounds and the human rounds
are you know we say that your price will
in the next round may go down by five
percent if it does are you still willing
to accept that price and then during the
processing we could have two similar
stations and it's possible that one of
them has its price go down and the other
one doesn't because of the order of
processes because of the order within
the machine round and but that's the the
largest difference that can emerge is
whatever the increment is for the the
human realm that's the the difference
can't can never be any larger than that
if the stations are identically situated
if they're differently situated there's
some stations that we don't need to buy
and other stations that we do need to
buy and of course those will get
generate different prices
start what yeah where did they come from
yeah so so we wanted them to be high and
and we took a look at so you know it's
this is partly finger in the wind stuff
and we took a look at you know based on
what the prices were in the recent a.w.s
three auction you know how many we have
our internal guesses as to how much
these licenses might be worth what's the
most revenue that we could hope to
generate from the forward auction that's
the most will ever be able to pay in the
reverse auction and so it's a
calculation of that sort where we looked
at you know what's the most we could
ever possibly pay if we gave all of the
revenues from the auction to the
stations and then raise that a little
bit because some of the prices are going
to be bid down and it was a process like
that that led to these together with you
know basic frankly investment bankers
were involved and so on we we took a
look at transactions what what prices
were people paying for television
stations we wanted these two look so
really high and so there was a lot of
consideration how much is the most we
might actually be able to afford how
much does it take might it take to
really you know turn heads and attract
interest and and then we're going to
count on the auction to bring the prices
down into a reasonable range you know
where there's competition for stations
you